les ivelines comptent
738179 foyers fiscaux et parmi eux 68 %
sont imposables ces 68 % de foyers
imposables ont permis en 2013 au service
des impôts de recouvrer un peu plus de 2
milliards et demi d'euros certains
contribuable P l'ISF l'impôt de
solidarité sur la fortune le service des
impôts des ivines a enregistré
15197 déclarations soumise à l'ISF cela
concerne les contribuables dont le
patrimoine net taxable et super à 1,3
million d'euros les contribuables ont
jusqu'au mardi 20 mai pour déposer leur
feuilles papier et jusqu'au 10 juin s'il
déclare en ligne en 2013 44 % des foyers
ivelinois avaient choisi ce mode de
déclaration si vous souhaitez des
informations des renseignement le
département dispose de 9 centres des
finances publiques dont un à 50 ans
Yveline qui sera ouvert sans
discontinuer de 8h30 à 16h du 5 au 20
mai